hey 42 here some advanced warning that
we're going to start with a tale
that might make you feel just a little
bit inadequate
especially if you've been spending
lockdown eating too much
and playing the sims but if you can
handle that
let's get right to it has the world ever
seen a human being as well rounded
as leonardo da vinci the bonafide
renaissance man a self-made polymath
the guy could do it all from his humble
start in life
the illegitimate son of a notary and a
peasant
born in a small hamlet in tuscany he
would go on to achieve
excellence as a painter and inventor who
contributed to civil engineering
chemistry geology geometry
hydrodynamics mathematics mechanical
engineering
optics physics pyrotechnics
and zoology that's right leonardo da
vinci made significant contributions
to more fields of study than you have
gcses
despite his undoubted genius da vinci
faced
well a lot of doubt in the same way that
the mona lisa was
for a long time considered merely a
well-regarded painting
rather than one of the most famous and
best-loved masterpieces in the world
da vinci's grand ideas were met with
skepticism
in the 15th and 16th centuries da vinci
made sketches for helicopters
diving suits war machines and more
well before they were ever actually
built
in some cases these wouldn't be built
for hundreds of years in the future
he even sketched a self-propelled cart
that could easily be the first
forerunner of the modern car but his
contemporaries weren't so
amazed with da vinci's doodles bayezid
ii an ottoman sultan who'd commissioned
da vinci as part of an engineering
project
rejected his proposal for a 280
meter single span bridge longer than the
typical bridges of the time
it would have been the longest in the
world but the sultan believed
the ambitious design was impossible
and da vinci didn't get the job mit
researchers
built a scale replica of the bridge in
to test whether the bridge would have
worked as intended
that is held itself up and together only
by the compressive forces within it
and lo and behold they found the design
was flawless whilst davinci was
exceptional for the sheer volume of
inventions he devised that were well
ahead of their time
when it comes to predicting how far out
inventions might change the world around
us
one profession stands out science
fiction authors
any decent sci-fi world must contain
well
science fiction that is technology or
inventions that transform the world
and bring with it a completely new way
of life
and sure enough the sci-fi community has
made some pretty bold predictions over
the years
and whilst we've yet to be overthrown
and enslaved by a
skynet style ai like in the terminator
films
there are plenty of inventions and
predictions
that have come true minority report
painted a wild picture of what 2054
would look like
but hey we're not there yet so it could
all come true
although one terrifying aspect of the
film has already come to fruition
amongst the eye transplant and mutated
physics
the targeted advertisement john anderton
is bombarded with
lines up fairly well with what we
experience on a daily basis
somehow another advertiser has got our
name
our likes and is trying to flog us a
product we mentioned in passing to a
friend
with an earshot of some smart device at
least they don't actually
shout at us yet the film also features
government surveillance that uses eye
recognition technology
which while still not commonplace is
definitely in use around the world
but widespread surveillance was
predicted long before that
you can't mention dystopian levels of
government spying without looking at
george orwell's 1984
one of the most powerful books in the
genre it paints a bleak picture of a
world where
big brother and yes that is where the
show's name comes from
is always watching it's hard to look at
the 2013 revelations about the nsa and
the widespread nature of surveillance of
entire populations
and not believe that we're closer to
orwell's vision
than the powers that would be like us to
think
take for instance the topic of social
ratings that has cropped up a lot lately
china has enacted a large-scale social
credit score system
to track and monitor its citizens
behaviour both
online and offline which i've discussed
in previous videos
if you don't behave how the state wants
you to or for example
post something the state doesn't approve
of on your social media
you can be denied loans despite having a
good income
as more and more countries consider
adopting social rating systems
the world is looking increasingly
dystopian every year
these days anything you say online can
be used against you
perhaps it'll be tomorrow maybe years
down the road
anyone with an online presence can be
under the threat of having their posts
and comments
twisted and used against them this is a
huge ongoing
concern for influencers such as myself
in short it's more important than ever
before
to protect your data and think twice
before posting
ambiguous photos of yourself or other
potentially compromising
information that's why kaspersky started
the kaspersky social ratings project
they are developing steps for what
people like you and me
can and should do to prepare themselves
and secure their private data follow the
link in the description
to learn more from kaspersky on how
social ratings can affect you
and how to better prepare and protect
yourself
where would sci-fi be without space
travel it's no surprise that many fans
believe
science fiction proper began with jules
verne who's being called the world's
first
full-time science fiction novelist
alongside
journey to the center of the earth and
20 000
leagues under the sea verne wrote from
the earth to the moon
in 1865 it tells the story of the
baltimore gun club
who builds an enormous space gun and
fire three people in a ship
to the moon verne was thorough in the
scientific details of his novels and
even performed calculations
on the requirements of the novel's canon
some of which turned out to be very
accurate
nasa has acknowledged that the columbiad
vern's fictional spaceship
closely resembled the actual apollo
spacecraft
whilst the enthusiasts amongst you will
know that nasa's command module for the
successful 1969 lunar landing
was the columbia both missions even take
off from florida
and land in the pacific ocean
similarities neil armstrong pointed out
during a tv broadcast
on his way back from the apollo 11
mission
from earth to the moon also details the
weightlessness that astronauts would
experience in space
something that verne would have had no
way of knowing at the time
putting a man on the moon wasn't the
only prediction jules verne got right in
his sci-fi
works his short story in the year
2889 imagined what life would look like
1 000 years into the future he described
the daily news as being spoken every
morning to subscribers around the world
rather than being read in newspapers we
didn't need to wait a thousand years
for this though just 30 odd years later
the first radio broadcast made listening
to the news a reality as well as radio
the 1920s gave us the iconic sci-fi
film metropolis one of the first
full-length films in the genre
despite receiving a mixed reception
including being panned by sci-fi great
h.g
wells it's grown to be considered one of
the finest silent movies
it wasn't until 1937 that we got our
first
proper robot and by proper i of course
mean that it was a seven
foot 260 pound steel bmf
called electro that could walk talk
count smoke and inflate balloons
you know your basic essential functions
robots
and their sci-fi imaginings continue to
advance with isaac asimov penning his
famous laws of robotics in 1941
in a short story that would later become
irobot
metropolis also featured video calling
but since there are some more famous
examples of that we'll revisit skype's
predecessors later
despite slating metropolis h.g wells
best known for the war of the worlds
also seemed to have the ability to look
into the future in his writing
in 1933 he wrote the shape of things to
come
a so-called future history predicted
a second world war starting in january
this estimate was only a few months out
and his detailed accounts of air raids
of berlin lined up with what would come
to pass a few years later
following world war ii author arthur c
clarke proposed some more peaceful uses
for the v2 rocket which the germans had
developed
clark reckoned the rockets could be used
to put satellites into orbit
and that if put it the right height
they'd stay
locked to the same point on the earth's
surface
this popularized the idea of
geostationary satellites
which still use the clark orbit today
for tv intelligence weather forecasting
and defense applications staying with
satellites
sort of we move in a seamless segway to
the
jameson satellite a short story by neil
r jones written in 1931 in it the
protagonist professor jameson
asks for his corpse to be sent into
orbit around the earth
hoping that the low temperature close to
absolute zero
preserves his body until it might be
resurrected
sure enough all it takes is 40 million
years of waiting before the advanced
cyborg race to zoroms
find him and bring him back to life
american academic
robert essinger who'd read the james and
satellite as a child
later founded the cryonics institute and
spent his lifetime dedicated to
cryonic's research
his own body alongside those of his two
wives his mother
and a few hundred other believers are
stored on ice in the hope
that modern medicine will one day be
able to restore them
cool but he made a serious novice
mistake
you don't freeze both your wives just
your favorite one
written the same year as the jameson
satellite aldous huxley's brave new
world
is a dystopian classic that also
predicted the widespread use
of chemical antidepressants soma is the
novel's
mood-altering pill which soothes and
placates the population
huxley's vision predated prescription
antidepressants by 20 years
but once the link between chemicals and
depressants was established
their popularity soared prozac quickly
became
ubiquitous in western society and was
the third most commonly prescribed drug
in the us
by 2008. from fifth place on the 20th
century's best english novels
we moved to a sci-fi novel that was
almost
universally derided for the quality of
its writing
the oddly named ralph 124
c 41 plus its title
a play on words as 124c
for one another maybe the peak of its
artistic merit
but ralph is packed with successful
predictions
alongside solar energy tape recorders
and not only television but even idle
channel surfing
the novel contains a detailed
description of exactly how radar would
work
when marconi made a working radar in
ralph may as well have been the
instruction
manual there's even a passage about
video calling
where a character uses a video phone
called a
telephoto to see and talk with a friend
but if we're talking about famous sci-fi
skype predecessors
we can't ignore 2001 a space odyssey
alongside the newspads that look
remarkably like
ipads the film's picturephone captivated
audiences
with multiple attempts to make them
successful over the years
in the very same scene dr floyd inserts
what looks like a credit card to start
the call
given they were far less common in the
1960s this prediction of the
ubiquity they later enjoy is fairly
impressive
credit cards were also predicted in
sci-fi as far back as 1887
in edward bellamy's novel looking
backwards which told the story of a man
who goes to sleep that
year and wakes up in the year 2000.
bellamy's description of these credit
cards included that each person
used his to procure at the public
storehouses
found in every community whatever he
desires
whenever he desires it which
totally obviates business transactions
of any sort
between individuals and customers
and well if that isn't a description of
ordering something off amazon and
collecting it from a self-service locker
i don't know what is sticking with
modern conveniences
arguably even more essential than a
credit card to many people these days
is a mobile phone alongside the tachyon
beams and photon
torpedoes star trek inspired the first
mobile phone
motorola engineer martin cooper based
his prototype on captain kirk's
communicator
although at two and a half pounds and
with just 20 minutes of battery life
i'm not sure many people would consider
it particularly
mobile by modern standards still
it paved the way for smaller phones that
eventually led to the screens
we love being glued to today star trek
also features replicators
that can print food and objects in
seconds and whilst i don't think these
directly inspired 3d printers
they definitely were a sign of things to
come there are even companies who now
claim to be able to separate
and put together individual molecules in
essence
allowing us to build almost anything
from its most
basic building blocks onto another
inspired handheld device
except this one definitely isn't
something you want to hold to your ear
nuclear physicist jack cover made the
first stun gun in the 1970s
and gave it its now household name
taser where did he get the word from
he chose it as an acronym for thomas a
swift's electric rifle referencing
the 1911 novel tom swift and his
electric rifle the key neared amongst
you
will have noticed the a isn't in the
book's title
and indeed tom swift is never given
any other names but cover realized the
word was far easier to pronounce with
another vowel in it
though tom swift's electric rifle is
used to hunt big game in africa and
can shoot through walls the real taser
was actually developed as a weapon for
air marshals
so they could stop hijacking attempts
without shooting a hole in the very
plane they were trying to save
firing a gun is one thing you're not
meant to do on a plane
another is have headphones in during
safety briefings and
takeoff at least but the development of
smaller and smaller earbuds
makes it even harder for air hostesses
to actually tell if
passengers are actually listening to her
instructions on how to secure a seat
belt
instead of trying to find a song on
their phone that perfectly matches her
flailing appendages
and yes you guessed correctly ear buds
are another invention that sci-fi
writers dreamt up long before they were
made reality
fahrenheit 451 written in 1953 and a
staple of english classes the world over
describes seashells which were tiny
wearable headphones
that fit inside the ear providing an
electronic
ocean of sound music and torque
what the novel didn't predict is the
awkward social encounters these would
create
when you start talking to someone only
to realize too late that he's busy
listening to something
infinitely more interesting than you
through tiny
invisible earbuds but hey it also
mentions friends communicating through a
digital wall
which is probably predicting facebook so
who needs socializing in person when you
can do it online
from the comfort of your toilet if you
fought predicting airpods on facebook in
1953 was impressive
how about predicting blogging in 1835
that's exactly what 19th century russian
prince no i'm not making this up
vladimir odofsky did in his novel
admittedly the novel was titled the year
so he overestimated how long it would
take for us to reach the point where
anyone and everyone could write a blog
full of angsty poetry and
buttock clenchingly enthralling stories
of self-loathing and anxiety
during a trip to the supermarket clearly
that was a higher priority for us than
vlad realised
but still for him to have written over
100 years before the dawn of the
internet that
houses would be connected by means of
magnetic telegraphs
that allow people who live far from each
other to communicate
and that the regular updates people
published would cover a family's health
household news thoughts and comments all
to be shared with the world
he definitely predicted over sharing
with total strangers who
really couldn't care less about how your
guinea pig is doing
or your toddler who also resembles a
guinea pig
maybe by the time we do actually get to
43 38
we'll all finally admit that we don't
give a about each other's kids and
pets
now there's arguably one science fiction
novel that stands head and shoulders
above the rest when it comes to
making predictions stand on zanzibar
written by john brunner in 1969
the book's title comes from a claim that
the start of the 20th century
that the world's population could all
fit stood up
on the isle of wight in 2010 when the
novel is set brother predicts
the earth's population will be 7 billion
and would thus require an area the size
of zanzibar
brother was almost spot on the world's
population reached 7 billion
in 2011 and that was just the first
of many impressive predictions
the book also includes the us being
plagued by terrorism
and random acts of violence often at
schools the rise of
china as america's most powerful rival a
european union of nations that
nevertheless sees the uk siding with the
us
gay and bisexual lifestyles becoming
mainstream
in-flight entertainment motor vehicles
running on electric fuel cells
global tv news channels sent via
satellite
laser printers the marginalization of
tobacco
following a social backlash a real-time
social network
much like twitter the list goes on
although one small detail is almost too
hard to believe
a world leader called president
obama barack obama of course
was elected u.s president in 2009.
though critics have called some of the
predictions of fluke
it's an impressive list nonetheless
and finally we finish on something that
is well
i'm not going to beat around the bush
it's not a highbrow sci-fi classic
it's the simpsons it's hardly a
reimagining of the technological limits
of our world and
yet it has famously got a fair few
predictions right
who would have thought that donald trump
would run for let alone become president
when that episode aired
in march 2000 but i'm not going to go
through various things the simpsons got
right because despite some accurate
social commentary
they're bound to have done so across 700
episodes
that's besides the point the reason i
want to talk about the show now
is a time that they not only predicted
the future but
actively influenced it a 1994 episode
featured a bully called kearney asking a
friend of his to take down a memo on his
newton which was apple's early attempt
at a personal digital assistant
the memo was meant to read beat up
martin
but the device misreads his handwriting
as eat up martha
this phrase became a mantra for apple
engineers years later when working on
improved ios software
their former director of engineering
said avoiding
an eat up martha moment motivated the
ios
team to ensure the keyboard and also
correct features for text input
were far more accurate so
perhaps the lesson here is that whatever
predictions are made for the future
good or bad we stand to benefit most
if we can learn from them and strive for
better
thanks for watching and don't forget to
check out the kaspersky social ratings
project
via the link in the description